you can ask somebody who's got a certain
religion political beliefs you ask them
who their hero is
you can learn a lot about them who is
the hero
or heroes of the antifa community
so it varies i remember when i was uh
and when i was part of the movement
there was people who liked chagavara
and who thought that he was like the the
epitome of anti-fascism
uh revolutionary tactics there's people
who also
uh took uh who liked the what is his
name
el chapo there we go
and you know they really enjoyed them i
can tell you that no one's looking up to
the true anti-fascist of uh
general uh eisenhower or you know people
like that they're always looking for the
people who are
who are revolutionaries and fighting the
capitalist system
um how about modern day modern day
people that are alive
modern day people are alive i mean um i
can't really
give any specific examples i know that
back in 2014
some of the uh the chapters uh some of
the
radical left they were looking
specifically to this woman who
um who fled to cuba after killing a
police officer
and she's actually i believe i think it
might have been in northern california i
can't remember
in 2014 they were trying to name a
building after her
maybe uc berkeley and i can't remember i
know it was in northern california
um and i mean she's she's wanted by the
fbi she's one of the most
wanted people and she's living in cuba
and the radical left is worshipping her
because she killed the police officer
and i mean this is the kind of people
that really they look up to people who
are
true quote unquote true revolutionaries
who are willing to take that step and
kill innocent people or innocent police
officers is that assad
shakur i think that might be it so okay
so those are some of the names they look
at as heroes and who do they look at as
absolute enemies like who is the enemy
the state number one
you know anybody who is
opposed to them is suddenly the enemy
but back in
uh back in my day it wasn't
it was they actually really despised
obama and they thought that obama wasn't
liberal or leftist enough to do it
because a lot of people have this
misconception that antifa
is against president trump or just
against republicans you know because
this tends to be more on the left side
of politics but what people really need
to understand antifa
is that their true enemy is our system
of government and our society as a whole
because they despise the uh
they despise capitalism they have this
this wrong idea that by destroying
capitalism
all of a sudden you're going to have
gender equality and racial equality and
everything's going to be nice and dandy
when as we've seen around the world in
several countries those places that
don't have a capitalist system more of a
marxist or socialist system
they're actually the most oppressive
governments in which
uh there's closer to slavery i mean for
example
in china right now we have um i forget
the name of the
the ethnic group the mongolians i
believe they're basically being put in
in in concentration camps and that's
what you get with the socialist system
do they look up to somebody like an aoc
or el hanomar or folks like that or no
surprisingly no they are not
left enough for them because um
it's kind of funny and this is um as a
conservative activist i've got an
opportunity to travel to a lot of
different college campuses
specifically at uc berkeley wow right
outside uh
their college campus there's this
bookstore called
revolution books and i remember seeing a
flyer from one of their events
saying how aoc's green new deal
was just a new capitalist uh a
plan to uh secure power and they were
criticizing her for being a capitalist
this is how far some of these antibiotic
radical leftists are
even aoc is a capitalist
so what is their ultimate vision what
are they trying to accomplish
obviously their stated mission is to
destroy fascism
but by destroying fascism they really
just mean and i can't stress this enough
i feel something like i'm just repeating
myself
but when they say fascism they mean
american society
and also just a capitalist system as a
matter of fact there's
in my book i i put this uh this antifa
chapter on twitter that they say the the
the fight against fascism will only be
one
when the capitalist system and smash and
i mean that's truly what they want they
will they have this wrongful idea that
capitalism and fascism
are the the the same system when
they're completely opposites